ces enfants venus d'une commune voisine
prépare un avenir lointain en replantant
des mets consolide aussi un futur proche
en aidant à récupérer les copeaux de
bois issu de l'arrachage de vieux arbres
ces copeaux sont le combustible utilisé
par la chaudière à bois installés dans
leur école depuis dix ans on a créé avec
un groupe d'agriculteurs et de
forestiers et en impliquant aussi les
collectivités locales une filière locale
de production et de valorisation de bois
déchiqueté le voit aujourd'hui et
l'énergie la moins chère en fait sur le
marché on est à entre 3 et 4 centimes du
kilowattheure contrôle fioul à 7 ou 8
et après il ya aussi un intérêt de créer
de l'activité locale à dire que nous au
travers de la filière on a créé trois
emplois
cette gestion des ne constitue pas une
manne financière conséquente pour les
agriculteurs il s'agit plutôt d'un
complément logique à l'activité
d'élevage l'arbre permettant de réguler
les effets des précipitations ou de
protéger les troupeaux enfin il y à là
tout paysage et on revient dans quatre
ans on aura 2 est qu'ils feront trois
quatre mètres de hauteur autour du
chemin
et là je vous fais le pari que les
randonneurs moi même en allant chercher
mais lâche jeu apprécié d'avoir un abri
et nous promener trois ans dans un
chevreuil
voilà c'est bien dans cette démarche là
et tout en recherchant une productivité
la filière bois énergie sans fard
recherche d'autres agriculteurs
partenaires pour augmenter la collecte
de bois et veut convaincre les
collectivités locales d'investir dans
des chaufferies bois afin de pérenniser
ce système de valorisation des airs